Have you heard of personalized peptide therapy using RGCC reported?
One company doing this is Neo7 ever heard of them.
Well, there's a lot of companies that are using peptides and doing personal peptide therapy.
My concern to address this of the Zoom or the past is that one
concern that you have to have with peptides is
is
the possibility of them stimulating growth.
Most peptide therapy, that's the whole purpose of peptide therapy is growth.
They're trying to stimulate cell reproduction for cell healing.
That's where all the money in peptide therapy is.
It's used very widely in athletics.
It's used widely in people trying to heal from injuries and things.
So, yeah, I'm all for new types of therapy.
I've just been careful with peptides because of the fear of stimulating growth.
So that would, but anything that can be proven that it can help with cancer, we need to be open to.